يبني جدار في الكونجرس لتعزيز حملته
للرئاسيه المقبله ولمساعدته على نبش سجلات
خصومه السياسيين والقانونيين الرئيس
الامريكي السابق بدا يعمل بقاعده تقول ان
احسن وسيله للدفاع هي الهجوم
37 نائبا برلمانيا جمهوريا في مجلس النواب
بالاضافه الى خمسه اعضاء جمهوريين في مجلس
الشيوخ في صف ترامب فوافق موقع اكسيوس
يتواصل ترامب الذي يواجه اتهامات جنائيه
في نيويورك عبر الهاتف مع مؤيدين له مثل
رئيس السلطه القضائيه في مجلس النواب جيم
جوردان ورئيسه مؤتمر الحزب الجمهوري
لمناقشه تحقيقات مع الرئيس الحالي جو
بايدن والمدعي العام لمنطقه ومن بين ابرز
الجمهوريين الاخرين في مجلس النواب الذين
يؤيدون ترامب جيم بانكس وروجر ويليامز
ومايك بو ست بالاضافه الى روني جاكسون
فضلا عن اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ
همس وماركوين هي خطوه جديده من الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب عله ينجو من
اتهامات اموال الصمت كما فعل في قضايا
سابقه بلال البجديني العربيه